okay thank you welcome everyone to the
finance and projects committee meeting
um apologies for the likeness of this
meeting but we've had other business fed
to attend to so we'll try and move
through this
reasonably
proficiently
um so apologies we do have one councilor
Stewart
um do we have any others
Korea
and Nigel
uh yeah cancel Scout and counselor Bond
Bond yes so can I have someone
second Leslie
all those in favor
um welcome at Zoom attendees
um if you're still there
um public forum we have none we do have
a minor late item which is
um
on the screens now so I need a move
Runner so you can do accept that as a
minor later
just sorry just the point of order the
chair
um bro
um Bond and skelt are not on this
committee uh apologies
yeah
I just thought it for the records a lot
of apologies they're not on attendance
no no no they're not even on the
committee yeah I don't need to apologize
they're just correct Mr chair
um apologies can't be received for
people who aren't on the committee yeah
but it's nice
we'll show that yeah yeah record that
thank you
so I I was just going to ask about the
main lead item we don't actually have a
paper on it I don't think do we let's do
in the public excluded section Council
oh this thing's good okay
so Leslie was moves can I have a
secondary thanks Tom all those in favor
all right
Vince carried
okay so the first item is
the minutes of the finance and projects
committee dated 21st of February
thanks Leslie second uh
Tom thank you all those in favor
aye against carried so the bigger bigger
pardon I was not at the meeting I kind
of second bit so somebody else
there thank you
so move that now all those in favor
against
carried
okay
um the next one
um extraordinary minutes meeting minutes
of the extraordinary meeting
for the pro projects
finance and projects committee held 21st
of March I'll move that as well thank
you loosely
Darren okay thank you all those in favor
instant carried
okay so item six business enhancement
and I think trust is going to present
there Trish is going to present it from
up here
um so this is just the regular update on
the business enhancement program is
counselors will require this is the
program of work which
developed
um to go along at this journey of
transformation and provides an update on
the number of projects that we've got
there is a late breaking item and there
um the rates online program project has
gone on has gone live as of today
so as rape has received their rates
notices
for the fourth installment in the next
probably week to 10 days they should hit
mailboxes they will have everything they
need to sign up online
to receive their next rates installment
which will be late July by email
so that is the um we have that up and
running now
but if there's any questions on those
projects and their progress
I'll take them
congratulations on the rates one that's
good news
[Music]
okay
any questions from the floor on the
report no
okay that being the case we'll
um can I have a move in second two
second or two receive the report I'll
move thanks Tom thanks ringy all those
in favor
aye against carried okay next one's
strategic capital projects report
who's coming at Lee
welcome Lee how are we all doing good
yourself not too bad
uh we'll start off the report by going
through the dashboard and any questions
on the dashboard
um I'll just quickly um
summarize the projects and then we'll
maybe take some questions on the
dashboard then we'll go through those
items on the report
um city streets obviously we went
through and had the opening of city
streets
um great to get to the end of that one
we're just going through all the sort of
final accounts snagging some minor items
um or finishes and bits and pieces on
that so yeah it's great to get to the
end of that project
looking like it's going to land
to probably to the ceiling of our budget
and we'd like to say we're just working
through those sort of final accounts and
bits and pieces with the contractor
obviously we've had some issues over the
contamination and that's through the
year uh and obviously it's finished
still quite a bit later than we we
originally planned
uh State Street stop Bank obviously
again we've put the last of the artwork
pieces in The Whale's Tale um hopefully
quite a few of you been have a look at
that uh magnificent piece of art that's
now been installed and there's just some
minor uh updates on the planting and
bits and pieces and some weeding in that
through there through which tapatani
have been doing for us
um that's going to return a small amount
of contingency looks like about 300 000
at the moment back to the uh Capital pot
uh again I think it's a really good
outcome of the project has been run very
well by the team we had some materials
Supply issue early on with overseas with
um shielding and bits and pieces but
they've really done well to get them
across the across the board
so a couple of a couple of them now in
the close phase which is great
uh banks on water main the physical
delivery of stage one is is complete we
are
um under the testing sort of phase at
the moment and the physicalities of it
we've come across one small minor leak
which is near the roundabout which is a
bit of a pain uh but we're just working
through that with the contractor in
carrying out that repair looks like a
um a couple of uh has failed there
rather than a weld which is which is
great so they've been able to identify
that coupler very quickly and over the
next uh we will they'll carry out that
repair and then we'll carry out further
further testing on that section of the
line
um the tender close for stage two and
unfortunately we didn't get to
um award that it was still significantly
over our budget and we didn't really
feel that we had the the right response
there we only had one response and the
team are currently working on
um other sort of procurement methods and
uh doing some diligence on a number of
companies outside the region who have
undertaken this sort of work and trying
to gauge their appetite to come down to
South London and get in and get amongst
it for us
on that
rugby park we're just about have that
report uh thrashed out for Council we've
had some submissions back from lighting
suppliers we have a good up-to-date
information and pricing to come to you I
think next month in a special f p
committee report
and the cab likewise with the rugby park
we've just about got that report this
was running a little bit late it wasn't
to come to this particular meeting but
uh due to a bit of Staff illnesses and
that uh within our contractors that's
running a little a little late and we'll
come to the special report next month
but that's uh
that's been well progressed
uh approaching 12 25 obviously that's
progressing again really well let's try
and put a positive dashboard this uh
this report
the main design team obviously been
appointed and we've started that work
with them on that steel is on site at
tidsbury and looking like it's going up
very shortly so that's on program as
well and then the insulated panel will
come in behind that so that physical
Project's going well for us
um we've also got a preferred supplier
now for the Tuatara enclosure so we can
we can crack on with that so overall I
think 1225 is is tracking tracking
wealth uh all on budget at this point uh
the experience brief is in the market we
carried out an experience our supplier
briefing
um last week that went well we had again
we had quite a lot of interest from
overseas suppliers with Australian
contractors appearing at the briefing in
person and online so again we're looking
like we're possibly going to receive
some overseas uh proposals for the
experience pace which is quite exciting
so yeah that's definitely a project
that's taking attention not only here in
New Zealand but obviously capturing the
imagination and attention of suppliers
in Australia
Bluff boat ramp we are I believe next
week or this week this week sorry I'm
actually going to be undertaking the
test piles
um in the bay there that's that's a
really exciting work
um the the team there the designers
there have gone and opted for one
oversized pile if it's a successful pile
we'll reduce the number of piles in our
design which will also make the West
Jetty a little bit cheaper to construct
which is
um you know good good strong potential
for that so yeah so again those those
drawings have been agreed with a project
control group and we're in we're in a
good we're in a good position there
we're sort of starting to pick up some
good Pace now on that uh project and so
yeah that's that's tracking particularly
well
and the housing and Innovation project
we had the first of the two suppliers on
site today just with their con with
their um subcontractors looking at some
tender queries for the pricing and
pricing closes on the I think 28th and
we'll receive them on the 29th for uh
for review
so overall the dashboard is looking more
green than Amber than it has for a while
it's great to get city streets and State
Street to a close
um some great results there and those
projects there are in Flight they're um
yeah they're going well so like take any
questions on the actual dashboard
questions from counselors
I've got one um or a couple of three
actually so just with the city
streetscapes yep so the contingency if I
read that right we've used 938 of the
1.5 contingency
but yet we were over budget but
two odd million
the
um we will well the idea is that there
that we will actually probably use all
the contingency once we finish the Tidy
Up with the contractors around extension
is a time and claims for contamination
and bits and pieces for that hence we're
showing that the estimate to complete
will be the full budget 20.8 but the
original budget was less than that
wasn't it the original well there was
actually a bit of a bit of a full power
within some of the reporting where we're
reporting the contractor
value that that expert only not the
um above and below not below line so it
was just showing the construction
numbers for quite some time until we
realized that the dashboard was wrong to
be there right so this the 20.8 includes
all the Consulting fees
um the total budget yeah so that was
that was actually a problem at fault
within the dashboard okay thank you and
then the cab refurbishment the 480 000
that's been spent is
because there was a bit of Maintenance
that was identified that needed to be
done does that amount that's been spent
include some maintenance be been done or
is it no that's just purely project
costs
boat rent my last question so the 1.8
million there is that
included in that budget is
parking and also a user pays
collection system not the user pays
collection system but some upgrade or
some tidy up of the car parking yes okay
yeah okay thank you
okay
um
oh sorry the fact that you touched on
that user pays thing which I I'm
strongly in support of
um when who who makes that decision do
we do we magnet as a council or is it
who makes that call on user pays for
that black boat ramp
oh that would that would come back
through the parks team to council yeah
and with inclusion from the bluff
community board yeah so it's been
discussed by the board and well yeah so
they wouldn't my view would be that they
would be you know have to recommend an
approach yeah and then that would come
through parks and up to the council and
once that agreed the physical delivery
of that would be to the pmo office
any other questions
no okay so um we've got
so that's four different motions there
um
I wanted to feedback
sorry sorry yeah I just wanted to
obviously the last FMP meeting we talked
about forecasting yeah about
incorporating that into the dashboard in
some which way
just wanted to get some feedback through
the committee around that
we've looked at different ways of doing
that whether we look at a yearly year by
year sort of forecasting against you
know tracking what I'll spend versus
forecast on a year by year basis or on a
shorter window uh basis it's probably a
more
um
valuable metric if we do it on a shorter
window which is we're probably proposing
two back two forward
so we come to the f p committee every
two months bi-monthly so we would look
two back at how we tracked and they're
looking to look too forward on how we're
looking to spend in the next two months
so you would always have a an
understanding of how we went
and how we're looking to go
um rather than taking it over a 12
months period so yeah so yeah you you're
talking primarily around a financial
um
reporting approach or you're talking
financial and progress against the
actual physical plan I suppose so I
suppose in response to the committee's
um comments at the last meeting around
that forecasting about having visibility
and how we are spending to our forecast
is what I've um what I kind of gleaned
from that
um yeah so we would probably propose to
show it in a smaller window rather than
a 12-month window just on that so we've
done a review of our 12 month pmo office
that's actually tracked uh projects uh
on a 12 month or a yearly basis and the
only rank song really is the only other
only project that's sort of sitting
without that sort of 10 15 of our
forecast and that's because we haven't
been able to get that tender across the
across the line all of the projects have
actually tracked within 10 15 of their
forecasts
um so we're we're doing okay in that
space but we'll try and bring that
metric in in a in a short window yeah so
so for example we've packed on 12 25.
yeah
I think what would be valuable to see
there if you look at your actuals we
were spent two five four six yeah 2.5
million let's say what will we forecast
this Bend yeah so so we can get a very
clear view of okay we're slightly over
at the moment but then we can forecast
that forward to say well yeah we're over
at the moment but overall we're still
within budget but equally we may be
under on some things because for me what
I think you know and the classic is the
um
you know the uh the choosing of the
um designers yes yeah so you know there
was some
um we will send a budget there yeah yeah
so I think from 1225's point of view we
are tracking forecasting spend not in
not too bad the storage facilities
tracking it quite quite well the 1225
main projects tracking forecasting quite
well yeah to a Towers probably a little
bit behind but in the grand scheme of
things of the overall budget in a
percentage Yeah view it's not too bad
yeah so I think it will just give
councilors confidence that hey we're on
track and but equally allow us to see
sort of what does that mean for us long
term and we've got probably an issue
coming up that we need that leans across
yeah another thing like we're also
looking to do is probably break those
projects out into this into this table
now there's now we've got a few more few
entering into close yeah otherwise it
becomes a bit of an unwieldy sort of
spreadsheet so if we uh if we did it at
this point yeah well certainly I've got
and I'm sure the council have Got
Confidence of the pmo officers managing
it very closely yeah but I think we just
need a slightly higher view from a
governance perspective yeah sure the
sense that things are on track as we
move along okay
okay Lisa thanks Mr chair I'm
comfortable after that discussion to
move all four of the recommendations
thank you
I don't have a second for that
okay thanks Tom all those in favor
aye against character
next one
just one inch update to show you
again
thank you again this is um this is the
regular um
Financial update because this is at
February rather than at the end of March
um it doesn't have the full
um you know we don't have a performance
report to this meeting that will come to
the extraordinary next month
um this gives a very high level approach
uh we're in treasury positions at
um the live and knit deep position
um and just a general update of in
relation to debtors um I'll take it as
read the one thing I will say that we do
have some fun some term deposits coming
due we are rolling those
um that come due next week and we are
refinancing the debt that comes due next
week as well
um
it will be much higher than perhaps they
are expecting that to be higher than
five percent
that is just where the markets are
falling but they are moving around so
a good love a quote on it but I doubt it
will go
okay any questions
I've got one what's their average cost
of boring dinner
one thing I hadn't calculated
um it is going up yes it is yeah
um we will certainly have it for next
month when we have the court the
treasury one but we are replacing
um some very low interest rates with
some very high um as you see we still
have till October
good old days
just allows me to do my mess in the
middle of the night but everything's on
track but not average cost
okay so being no questions on any of
that report
I'll move the reports received thank you
Darren thanks Leslie
all those in favor I'd carried so let me
ask a question I haven't done that a
bigger pardon but could it ask a
question about the um the debt ceiling
cup which is set at 2.5 times total
revenue unrelated to interest repayments
it's based off your rates it's because
it's based off revenue and biggest
Revenue item as their rates take
so it's two but it can be slightly
higher as uh the mayor often reminds us
it can be higher than that but it's
currently set at 2.5 lists 100 million
um uncle Capital well ichl
it's a blunt mechanism
okay so that brings us to the end of the
we've moved
all right come so
we're supposed to
I thought we'd done that sorry so Ken
we've had a mover once again can we pass
the motion to receive the opponent to
update
all those in favor
carried okay
now we're at an end happy to move us
explicitly seconded thanks Darren all
those in favor all right all right first
carried